are you rolling ready to i don't know if
we still do intros do we do intros does
that still think i mean not really
haven't done an intro in a while this is
the intro welcome to boo-boo
phobia
[Music]
are these fingerprints new were those
there before just house new i could not
tell you what's new i think the eyeballs
up there are new eyeballs what are you
talking about
look up oh my god
they're not new for me but i think
they're new for you probably yeah
probably hi bud oh can you go retrieve
um
the oh god what is it i think what
they're called they're in the closet
over there uh that door swings open when
you walk up to it oh come on don't do
this to me man don't do this to me well
yeah what are you talking about
is this bad wait is this good is this
funny i just wanted to see the room that
they had the adjacent room but like they
made it real creepy as you approach i
don't want to
i
i can't even see do i have a flashlight
was there a flashlight
no no we're not enough
you're safe here this is a safe stop
do
[Music]
this i think nothing's actually
happening this is a joke
god jesus
no i saw it i saw it it happened it did
it okay
god
all right well that's uh we really like
to keep our skeletons in the closet i
almost got up and ran away it's been too
long since i've played a scary game i
think yeah man my body was like nope
time to go
speaking of skeletons in the closet uh
zoom into every picture on this board
and do a jump scare sound like
okay cool thank you
just leave that in exactly as it
happened
the final jump scare
we all look really excited to go ghost
hunting you guys want to get in the van
and drive to the house i'd love to get
in the van with you guys yeah man i'm
ready guys i'm not getting the hat level
1536
well someone has to carry this team so i
figured might as well be me wade and i
are both really good at this mark what
have you been doing yeah bob's like
three times your level dude you're right
yeah you're right but also ew fools
i'll let bob lead the way in this but
we're gonna start up though here we go
i'm ready
hi
you're not who i remember you being
hello hello
oh hello
hello
yeah uh bobby you're not gonna remember
you being but i didn't recognize you at
first and you were very silent so i was
just like okay i'm the guy in the bra
i'm the guy in the brown jacket right
yeah i see that yeah you are wade you're
good at this game what kind of ghost are
we hunting do you know already oh oh
it's a cougar
so what
oh i thought you never mind uh the ghost
type is bro it's definitely going to be
a ride you a ride oh yeah press j j is
your journal and they've changed it now
to where you can
you can see your uh cursed items under
items your overview actually shows you
the ghost's name and your objective so
you can see that anywhere now you want
to come back to the bus
oh they changed how the evidence works
yeah this works differently now so you
can actually just click on a ghost to
circle it if you just want to make a
guess and run away right um you can
cross something out if you want to rule
something out like if you want to rule
out a ghost or rule out a clue
the ghost menu you can click on each
ghost to see what evidence you need and
like the oh this characteristic is
better it used to be the case where one
of us dies in order to hear the others
clearly they need to talk through the
radio i don't know if that's still the
case or not oh you can talk through the
radio don't die well you can hear other
people talk to the writer you can't if i
die you won't be able to hear me if
you're still alive but i can hear you
but he can hear us on the radio okay so
if i die and you guys figure out that
it's a banshee you guys can talk to them
all right it's a bad she's sorry you
died little a-hole
if the ghost is hunting and you talk at
all apparently i can hear you and find
you and kill you so during a hunt you
gotta be real curious
whooshing coming inside the door
look there's a telescope over here
aimed at kind of the post
i guess it's probably a pretty narrow
field of view because it's such a long
oh the sky moves i can really tilt it to
look into nancy's window over there it's
real creepy that we have this on our
front porch
out here boys
what's inside the wind is inside too no
no the clouds the clouds cruising no but
also it is it is windy inside moon lixie
and turn the moon into a jump scare
darcy what's stargaze stargaze
all right i'm doing it
uh where should i put up the camera
i guess well anywhere for now but we
need to figure out which room to ghost
these in where are you
i love that and i'm so sorry i didn't
look for where power is i'll try to find
power uh
dear ghost where are you how do i put
the camera on the uh the tripod
uh so set the tripod on the ground and
then if you aim the camera at it you'll
see like hovering over i think you can
press f when you see that camera got it
it looks like you're
i might be putting my dick on the tripod
yes is there supposed to be a skeleton
foot on the floor
oh so that's the bone we need to get a
photo of that we get extra money we get
a photo of it then we pick it up i'm
gonna set up another tripod in the next
room or in the basement wherever you
guys think is best
uh the power's in the basement we gotta
go down there anyway
all right sounds good
sounds good uh
a butt mess with whoa
[Applause]
i was in the back bedroom go back into
the left room i was spirit boxing i said
are you here can you hear me and it was
all oh the shower's on that's what
you're saying oh the shower is shower
the water's running uh do you need any
there's not a shower in here where is
the ghost shower
right here next to me it's uh okay guys
it's not showering it's just on i'm
gonna i'm gonna move the camera from the
front room to the to the basement i
would maybe have it face this hallway
mark
are you guys seeing what i'm seeing
what's uh what's this oh what's this
card
here i'm gonna throw
i'm gonna give you a card uh it's on the
ground oh that's the cursed item hey let
me get a photo of that
yeah
it looks like a
bunch of squigglies to me all right hang
on there we go you got whoa oh cool did
you just sit on the ground oh
stop talking on the radio
i drew i drew a card and it said the
wheel of fortune and i thought that was
a good thing but the door
lights off
oh mark was talking come on
oh oh
is it over bob bob no what car did he
draw
death
bob can you hear us
rest in pieces bob
i got bad news i got bad news i got bad
news i got i got dude i got i got bad
news wheel of fortune the fool uh i got
bad news i got bad news the hermit the
fool i got bad news i got bad news
the tower the fool i got bad news
oh
i don't think the cards work while it's
hunting
i think i'm fine it's not hunting
definitely see bob your your problem was
not drawing enough cards
it's definitely still hunting it's
there's no way it's still oh oh no
hey hey come on now
see i told you
bob uh you all right
um bob just stay right there if you
would thank you for the cup i'm seeing a
nice photo of you doing the ymca or
whatever it is you got going on
that's great bob your neck seems to has
disappeared um
just wanted you to know that you know
what we can test this now you're dead
bob uh you can hear us right now right
if you can hear us well throw the cup
between our feet baby
beautiful uh we're gonna talk using the
normal talk
so i guess tell us how we sound right
now
can you hear us right now we're going to
hear us now rip a painting off the wall
and throw it
i don't know can you do that oh
he's trying if you if you hear right now
put the coffee cup uh on the couch or
something
oh oh my god he's speaking to us it
still is ranged so he wouldn't be able
to hear us if he was not there so bob
if he if if bob can hear us that means
he's the ghost oh god
bob
bob i forgot about the whole ghost
bob where is it point it out throw the
coffee cup in the central direction
oh that's not a good sign thank you bob
oh oh that's getting close
bob if i'm about to die throw the coffee
cup at me
i think i'm good
wait why aren't you oh my god bob stop
it
bob is that you oh i'm about to die
[Music]
no me
that's right you're on your own now mark
what do you mean
oh god what why
[Music]
why am i
all right uh okay
um
well this ghost
is a little aggressive um
i'm gonna use my night vision now
because that'll help
um if you guys
see that i'm about to die
just start throwing things at me
okay thank you pals okay if you if you
guys want to offer me general guidance
on where to go by throwing things in
that direction also
is that the death cup or set to go their
cup
i'm guessing i'm guessing it's to go
there come
if it's go there to my death i'm gonna
be very mad
okay all right i'm in the room
what must i do
uh-huh is that a teapot okay the the the
the the bunny the bunny
i don't see anything on the camera but
it's getting blurry it's getting glitchy
that's probably a good sign right
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hey guys
all right
that was terrible you all um
did great
but despite your greatness that was one
of the worst times i've ever been a part
of in my life so
all right my advice would be
do better and that's pretty much it
we're going to another house because i
feel like we need a little bit practice
before we go to a harder location uh-huh
so let's try let's try this house
just to be clear we're playing this on
professional right
yes this is the third hardest difficulty
it's not nightmare but it is
not easy why don't we drop it
just like a squeeze down oh uh no
okay i appreciate the democratic process
that we went through there on that good
work
[Music]
are we are we just merging sacks right
now
what's going on
so power's in the garage our sanities
are all good
no activity right now because we're not
in there yeah your radio is real good
man once again very windy inside this
house
like sounds extreme yeah it sure is
perfectly windy just the way i like it
i'm gonna set this up by this tv looking
uh down this hallway kind of like
getting a wide view oh hey there's a rib
cage on the table mark is that yours or
is that something i should get a photo
of i'm sorry oh that is i've never seen
that before it's not mine i was holding
it for a friend
oh yeah okay whatever you say
a camera shutter just went off in the
basement
what in the basement no that was that
was me taking a photo up here but
there's a phone ringing up here
somewhere yeah
i don't hear that
i hear nothing on the phone i'm gonna
put this camera in the basement did
someone else grab the other tripod
it's in here oh there's a camera on a
tripod in the dining room i oh we need
the camera brought into this bedroom uh
the ghost was in this bedroom over here
i can put the camera on like a desk
right how do i rotate the camera in the
placement
oh hey
[Music]
how do i rotate the camera in the
the mouse wheel oh
no so while you're aiming down at the
thing you just left click to place it
okay
so while i'm aiming left ah
yeah you'll like see the silhouette also
i think i just saw my breath for a
second we might have freezing temps in
here no way i just want to let you guys
know that we found evidence of the
paranormal on ema emf reader so that's
pretty good that's pretty good also the
ghost's name is
chakras confirmed i'm going to uh double
crucifix the bedroom so we don't die
immediately
i'm going to uh get a motion sensor
and a something else temperature
jumper temper why mark why are you just
right it looks like you're smashing the
keyboard with your face
man dude how do you how do you control
it
i just walked up and you were all
i mean yeah what of it oh
ghost orb on bedroom camera ghost orb
yeah little yeah wait there's something
you see that yeah that is an orb go
store bond
oh hey heywood go store bond camera
ghost orb on camera yeah yeah the only
thing about the ghost storms i will say
is they added a ghost called the mimic
and the mimic if it were to be gives off
a fake ghost orb oh
what does that look like so so look like
that same it looks like a fake one
well so for a mimic you can get four
pieces of evidence uh-huh only the ghost
orb isn't technically a part of evidence
for the mimic it just gives off a fake
one
yeah i'm going back in boys
did you get emf five did you get emf
five
the highest was three
roger that no five no five i have
briefing temps i have freezing temps
minus eight point six celsius right now
in the bedroom all right good good good
uh do you want to bring in one of the uh
the semen lights when you come in yeah i
got you all over that perfect
oh something just booped
in the
in
okay just checking just checking so
that's it there's a motion detector on
the bedroom now because that's one of
our goals or whatever i see
that was the ghost detective ghost
presence with motion sensor is checked
off the board okay so it's in that
bedroom that wade is currently in right
now
look look at it look at woods oh he
turned around look at wade's ass i put a
book down and i've got the uh that's
nice ass the dog
yeah look at the window
like down like under the window i
thought something moving a little
further to your left yeah
uh no like face the window though and
like on the floor turn your light off
and dance around a little
yeah could you back up to your left uh
could you back up to your left actually
well not really there's a bed to my left
go backwards yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just like that and now look on the
ground oh perfect perfect now look at
the ceiling but then also look back down
on the floor yeah there you go great
oh yeah that's good
uh keep looking there's something above
you really weird and poofy yeah
yeah oh it's on the ground no it's on
the ceiling oh it's on the ground it's
on the ceiling ah keeps flipping back
and forth keep an eye on it
i'm gonna sell this dick the door just
open jeremy you're fine you're fine um
now turn around look straight into the
camera lick your lips and pinch your
nipple
oh god i got a good pinch that's good
that's good that's good
that's good i like that that's sorry
sorry that's supposed to be for me and
mark
oh oh okay
just you guys won't show that footage
right what footage all right what am i
looking for this door the inside outside
of that door inside outside of door you
should see your hands
how many fingers normal amount
oh god i can't uh normal amount normal
fingers confirmed
what does that mean it could be hantu
seems like it's a han too
i could still technically be a mimic too
so it's haunted or mimic what are the
odds for a minute we would also get
spirit box so if there's a spirit box in
here we can test it
there is a sphere box on the desk in
there i think all right coming back in
wait do i need to grab anything else
like salt or something
i don't know what all of our optional
objectives are so if we have an optional
then yet
we need to discover the ghost and we
need to have a member of our team escape
the ghost during a hunt that's easy
i never do the escape ones
of course you don't you wouldn't
i like money i'm a coward oh
uh you're good activity level oh
activity levels at five be aware wade
your sanity is dropping
[Music]
activity is spiking activity nine
i'm out all right activity's going down
nothing on the spirit box so i'm
assuming it's a haunted yeah he's pretty
bad yeah you you chill out man you relax
let me give you a shoulder rub just bend
over oh thank you let me get some drugs
with that yeah perfect that'd be good
yeah yeah yeah oh no let me rub your
shoulder uh really stretch that lumbar
down to the ground touch your toes
okay
get the kick grab the camera
yeah just keep stretching straight hold
that
stretch it stretch
stretch that's good that's good
yeah more more if you can yeah that's
great all right look at the camera look
at the camera you face face him
yeah that was good that really uh look
at your sanity see it helped look at
that man look at that man oh instant fix
instant fix well are we going to say han
hantu
yes do we need to do anything else
the only other thing we could
potentially do to get extra fundage is
get a photo of the ghost or find the
cursed object and get a photo of that uh
i'm not gonna say something strange
about these pictures but uh can you guys
look in your journal of the pictures we
just took and tell me if you see
something strange uh yeah i don't see me
you probably don't see you
i see both of you
yeah interesting interesting
perfectly normal to take photographs and
never be able to see yourself yeah yeah
all right sure sure every low
self-esteem person dream photo
all right well uh i guess we're good
then right mission accomplishment unless
you want to find the cursed object yeah
we're good is there a cursed object in
there there's always a cursed object in
every house oh god all right should we
let's do it alright camera mark
what was that nothing waiting i have the
cameras all right good to know good
so uh
in your journal you can see cursed
possessions there's a haunted mirror a
voodoo doll a ouija board summoning
circle music box
or tarot cards could it be in a drawer
if they're tarot cards yes
if it's a mirror it's probably hanging
up on a wall somewhere it's like a
silver round
mirror oh god well i got a creepy doll
here but it's a bear
got a rabbit the voodoo doll has like
pins and stuff in it
all right oh it's the mirror uh the
mirror looks like yes please yeah
where are you
uh right down the hall it's right there
oh you think we would have seen that oh
oh yeah if you pick it up and you hold
it it'll show you what room the ghost is
then but it drains your sanity and if
the mirror breaks the ghost hunts
immediately
oh mark pick it up sure
how oh do i need an empty aha all right
i'm running outside i'm running outside
all right cool i got it i don't think
you can use the cursed object outside
you i don't want to use it i'm going to
sell it no yeah no if you're not going
to use it
you want it here yeah well i was going
to sell it i want to use it throw it at
the ground what happens yeah
all right i'm watching
bob
go in the closet bob
oh he's very dead do you hear no he
might be fine
bob fight it
on the bright side he had a camera mine
was out of photos here let me get a nice
photo of that
uh bob if you can hear us
yeah uh we're leaving oh look at that
activity spike wow
yep that is the activity spike of our
friend being murdered
well good job uh bob uh get in the van
uh
all right uh make sure you uh you
clicked on your evidence make sure you
clicked on haunted it has a big nice
circle around it yeah big nice circle on
han too
all right uh
gg's all around gg no re hello everybody
yeah i didn't uh i didn't get that i
thought it would break that fast i
didn't understand yeah that broke real
quick i think i don't know if it's
random how long it gets or no i don't
know how that works
yeah cursed objects are um
pretty on the mark if you get the music
box and it plays music
near the ghost the music box will stop
and it'll hunt immediately the cursed
objects are scary man i don't screw with
those too often all right fine i get my
photo and i run all right whatever you
say man whatever you say coward well two
of the three of us lived that time so i
feel like we've really graduated from
learners to masters so i'm gonna take us
to the campsite all right okay good i
like the sound of camping
i think we're ready for that i love big
open spaces full of nothing sounds like
a really great place to hide we got a
busy few months ahead of us so why not
kick this camp off with a scary story
i do like scary stories but hold off
until we get there there's a nice
campfire for us to tell it around bob do
you not know what i'm talking about
kind of cut you off there buddy that's
my bad that's okay
what is that was that a reference to
something bob do you not know what
that's your preference
howdy camper
made it just oh
right right right
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay i got
it i got it okay
campsite so we're gonna do a little
exploring before we go like actually
looking for the ghost hardcore i want to
show off some fun sights
cool cool cool thai you guys just want
to explore on your own i don't have to i
don't have to show you everything if you
guys are exploring your own you really
don't i'll take a digital camera and a
film camera so i get all the options
maple lodge campsite um
all right
oh
radio tech radio check ready to check
john madden
john
madden rivers
ready
yeah this is
is the dope
carlton of camping except for this loser
who apparently brought so much stuff
that their cat is just jam-packed and
nothing including themselves
they're so rich they got a tent for
their stuff
this this is their shed tent
[Laughter]
um i think i made it to the cafeteria
tent
a lot of beans
what is this a bow
i have it's freezing temperatures over
here is that something really yeah
that's definitely
all right cool i see nothing on the uh
yeah that was outside the cooking tent
here by the s'mores what not
wait did you hit the power so we can
turn this fire on or what
yeah but you need a lighter for the fire
man this this guitar is glimmering
this is beautiful
did you think campfires are lit with
power yeah
you just like turn it on and off the
fire in my house you just switch on the
wall yeah that makes sense
yeah is that not how fire works
it might be also a nice little blair
witch uh
thing here on this totem
totem is it a cursed object
no it's just a curse to look at oh i see
what you mean no that's a child's uh
creation it's the glory of the
imagination it's beautiful i don't like
that one end of each of those sticks has
been sharpened but not the other end
yeah it's a little weird
bob
bob radio check bob
bob radio
what
bob
uh wade
what happened to bob i don't know what
bob i don't know are you there i'm gonna
go back
bob
okay all right well then
okay
that's good probably light just blue
light blue
ah don't worry mark i'm gonna light the
fire for you buddy okay thanks pal you
do that wasn't there an electrical box
like i said
yeah wasn't there an electrical box
somewhere here
uh
the power is over by the big house
around to the right there's a house i'm
gonna go explore the big house you hear
me screaming it means i'm dying
on the dock
oh wait no power is good i just turned
on the lights there's light switches
oh yeah the ghostbusters just literally
exploded
yeah yeah i just wanted is exploding
lights a thing
that we can check out
just for the ghost being a dick
um where's that power can change where
it's at here but i can show you guys
what the generator looks like if you
want to see it i've seen i've seen a
generator before
are you sure
yeah
oh mark you gotta come over here man i
don't know where here is uh the dock
broke
there's a dock
man i gotta do some cardio
i
i am out of here
like two steps and i'm done so yeah i'm
glad you guys mentioned i was gonna say
anything but man yeah
you guys really gotta turn on the lights
on the way over it is dark
it is much nicer it's a nicer ambiance
yeah
okay
okay
oh this is lovely
oh hi
hey well that's weird all right well
that's good
i think power did just go out
i see
i can go fix it i think i don't know
where the generator is it's right there
it's a big red generator that's how you
know it's a generator
well why are the lights off then that is
a good question i don't have an answer
to it you have to turn them back on i
guess that's dumb all right so we still
don't have any sign or hair of this uh
ghost right you see anything oh we
certainly saw the freezing temperatures
yeah
by the campfire oh then why are we
wandering around
that's a great
question okay thanks buddy thanks pal
oh whoa what was that radio just went a
little fuzzy
radio check radio check
it's here it's right here
you're dead no don't die don't die don't
die
bob don't die
come get me ghost
oh
oh that
yeah i hear him
i mean maybe i shouldn't
get because why is it all the way over
here i gotta get out of here
god damn my cardio
oh oh oh oh can of beans where can it be
where did you drive bob
bobby you'd be gonna lead us to you you
could get on discord if you want oh hey
bob
bob if you turn your voice to like a
reverb ghost ghostly voice
and come into discord i think
oh god
[Laughter]
guys did you see the ghost
oh god no
all right uh well um uh i um whoever
died
we can talk now
hey
hey that's not deafened so mark can hear
our ghostly conversation i don't know he
can hear it
[Music]
oh
no no no no
such a helpful ghost he was right here
[Laughter]
were they helpful
[Music]
you